ich jetzt nicht sitzen würde würde ich
aufstehen mich tief verbeugen und zwar
von den Frauen im Iran denn
unglaublichen Kampf ausfechten die
wirklich etwas wissen kann der auf die
Straße gehen und nicht nur auf die
Straße gehen die erleben ihre Gesundheit
ihrer Familien und ihre ganze Existenz
riskieren nach 40 Jahren Mullah Diktatur
gibt es im Iran offenbar immer noch die
Reste eines bürgerlichen Gesellschaft
die den Frieden und die Freiheit
schätzen und das sind unsere Verbündeten
die wir bis jetzt im Stich gelassen
haben weil uns die wirtschaftlichen
Beziehungen mit den Muller terror-system
wichtiger waren diese Frauen sind
großartig und wenn ich wenn ich mir
überlege wenn ich am meisten bewundere
dann sind das an der erster Stelle die
Frauen im Iran und zweiten Stelle die
Ukraine die sich verteidigen und die
nicht kapitulieren wollen auch nicht vor
einem atomaren Drohung aber zurück zu
den Frauen das ist eine absolut
unerwartete und von allen unseren
Experten nicht vorhergesehene Geschichte
das ist dieses widerstandspotenzial dort
gibt und wie helfen wir diesen Leuten
deshalb bei kleinen Demos gegeben aber
im Prinzip ist Schweigen im Walde nicht
wahr unsere Feministinnen reden über die
gender Sternchen überhaupt Quoten über
die transophobie in diesem Land es gibt
keine große Demonstration niemand geht
hier durch die Straßen wirst du Zeit das
Casa Konflikt zwar und ruft zum Beispiel
Mula Frauenmörder oder Müller
Kindermörder verstehen sie wir lassen
die Leute im Stich das ist das ist das
was wir am besten können nämlich Leute
im Stich lassen den weck mich dann aber
schon toll im Stich gelassen und
Tschechien im Stich gelassen und ich
vergleiche sehr wohl Geschichte weil
geschichte wiederholt sich nicht aber
sie macht spiralische Bewegungen und
kommt oft ohne es zu wollen zum selben
Ziel also nochmal
die Frauen im Iran wenn ich nicht
verheiratet wäre würde ich jetzt nach
Iran fahren wenn wir dort eine Frau
suchen ich glaube es stimmen alle am
Tisch zu dass man selbst verschiedene
Verehrung davor haben kann es gibt ja
Aktionen wie beispielsweise in
Frankreich da schneiden sich
Schauspielerinnen ein Stück der Haare ab
die Haare sind nicht es ist immer so ein
Stück die beiden sehen von Aktionen wie
dieser ich weiß woraus ich hinaus wurden
es ist eine symbollehandlung sie setzt
wenig um sie bewirkt wenig aber sie
macht vielleicht den Leuten im Iran Mut
und sind mobilisiert andere ich weiß es
ist eine minimalistische Handlung es
bringt nicht viel aber es bringt immer
noch mehr als einfach zu Hause zu sitzen
und sich zu grämen ich tun gut zum
Beispiel bringen wir haben den die
Diskussion Iran und diese Atom über die
atomanreicherung Atomwaffen Diskussion
und man wäre sogar am besten bereit zu
sagen man würde wieder Iran in die
Welthandelsorganisation aufnehmen wieder
am wirtschaftlichen Leben
internationalen handelsströmen teilhaben
lassen wenn man denn dort mit den
Abkommen trifft man vergisst dort
vollkommen ah diese innenpolitischen
Schwierigkeiten mit denen sie ja wieder
und noch viel mehr das um den Iran herum
konventionelle finden Kriege finanziert
werden also wir reden gar nicht darüber
dass die im Irak der thesien im Libanon
im Jemen in allen an selbst in Saudi
Arabien sorgen sie für Unruhe in jedem
angrenzenden Land unterstützte Iran
konventionelle Kriege und wir sind
der einzige der hier sind bereit
unterwegs ist diese wieder als deutsche
Bundesregierung wieder in die Welt
Staatengemeinschaften punktu Welthandel
aufzunehmen nur wenn er etwas unterlässt
das Atom das Uran anreichert also alles
andere übersehen wir und machen wir und
das kann er tun finde ich entsetzlich
bleiben wir einmal bei den Frauen im
Iran wir wollen ja auf Herr Bruder these
eingehen wie sie stehen Sie dazu also
ich kann total gut nachempfinden was sie
sagen Herr Bruder das nämlich ja eine
Perspektive und ein also ein Anerkennen
praktisch für diese Leute letztlich auch
bedeutende Perspektive also Symbol
Handlungen sind gut aber ich kann mich
erinnern ich war ja viel in der
arabischen Welt unterwegs und ich meine
spreche auch selber arabisch und wenn
ich mich daran in der sogenannte
arabische Frühling was da in den Ländern
passiert ist viele Leute sind auf die
Straßen gegangen haben demonstriert
haben gesagt wir wollen uns um sozusagen
dem Westen annähern wir wollen diese
Diktatoren loswerden und was ist
passiert dann sagten sie mir nach einem
Jahr oder zwei Jahren und ihr redet
damit sie sie anstatt mit den Leuten zu
reden diese Revolution machen und mit
denen zu überlegen wir wir den Staat
anders ihm gestalten können und wie wir
letztlich also ich bin ein großer Freund
von dieser Idee dass das mit der
mediterrane Raum praktisch also ein Teil
von Europa sein musste in irgendeiner
Form die kenne ich nicht und die müssen
wir diskutieren im Stich lassen ich weiß
es jetzt noch nicht es ist vielleicht zu
früh zu sagen aber ich habe Angst dass
ich dieses Szenario um sozusagen
wiederholt dass die Leute die dann
demonstrieren und da irgendwie erst mal
riskieren auch mitunter ihr Leben und
dann nach ein paar Monaten kann man
sagen okay wir haben das ins Banken
gebracht vielleicht ist da was passiert
wir wissen Ägypten passiert ist oder in
Tunesien oder auch anderen oder in
Syrien ich meine das hat ja auch damals
so angefangen und was ist jetzt was ist
jetzt in Syrien nach dieser Zeit ja und
ich meine haben wir nicht diese Leute im
Stich gelassen oder haben wir auch nicht
die Demonstrierenden Ägypter im Stich
gelassen ja wir haben sie zumindest
nicht ermuntert auf die Straße zu gehen
es war ein genuiner Vorgang aus der
Gesellschaft aber sie wollten eine
Perspektive
Bewunderung für die Leute wissen Sie
diese Perspektive
korrupten Gesellschaften und Systeme
nicht mit pandemonstrationen ändern wenn
sie keine Eliten haben wenn sie keine
gebildeten Leute haben wenn ihr ganzes
politisch sie sagen das ist in Ägypten
keine Eliten und keine gebildeten Leute
gibt es einige Leben bereits in Europa
weil sie es doch nicht ausgehalten habe
es gibt auch ja andere sind nicht im
Stande die Gesellschaft zu verändern und
das hat offen was zu tun mit der
Geschichte dieser Gesellschaften mit der
religiösen Orientierung mit dem Mangel
an Bürgerrechten wir können von Europa
aus nicht Gesellschaften zu ihrem Glück
steuern und ich finde wir haben schon
genug Steuern nicht aber eine
Perspektive anbieten für diese Menschen
die eben dieses System ändern wollten
Institute
reinholen und Fragen finden Sie denn das
Druck für die Frauen im Iran ja
vielleicht sagen wir auch einfach mal
demonstriert wird in unserem Land
natürlich nur eine symbolische Handlung
aber immerhin etwas also wichtig ist
dass man auf Unterdrückung aufmerksam
macht so und ist ja genau das was jetzt
auch wenn sich nur ein Stück der Haare
abschneiden aber es geht ja darum dass
man dass man eine Symbolwirkung macht
und damit auf das Problem aufmerksam
macht denn viele bekommen das ja gar
nicht mit ja manche Medien berichten
darüber auch gar nicht und das ist schon
total traurig das ist derzeit mit der
eisbucket Challenge und alleine sagen
sich wichtiger machen als
Mainstream wissen Sie wissen ich kenne
den kämpfe für Kinderschutz und das sage
ich ja immer wieder wir gehen für alles
auf die Straße blacklab matter gegen
Homophobie für LGB Kitty und all das und
doch und auch viele Männer Digger für
Kinderschutz und dann haben wir nämlich
in Deutschland das gleiche geht kein
Schwein auf die Straße obwohl jeden Tag
Kinder zu zu 100 in unserem Land
missbraucht werden aber das ist genau
das man muss es anstoßen das ist genau
das wie ich dieses Thema und andere für
Kinderschutz machen ist es wichtig dass
diese Frauen machen der Unterschied ich
riskiere hier in meinem Land dafür zum
Glück noch nicht mein Leben diese Frauen
und da hat er natürlich Recht das
absolute respekt das wird dass sie das
da machen wenn sie und das was sie sich
da was sie da machen und was sie die
Gefahren der sich ausgeben die will man
sich ja nicht vorstellen aber ob das
ausreicht wenn sich ein paar Stars ein
paar Herrchen und ihre likes vor allen
Dingen generieren wollen weil sie wieder
mal eine Mainstream generieren glaube
ich nicht dass das ausreicht da muss
viel mehr passieren also doch eher als
bucket Challenge nee garantiert nicht
ich glaube schon aber vielleicht sollten
sie noch ein bisschen mehr machen als
ich nur die Haare abschneiden vielleicht
sollten Sie einfach wirklich auf die
Straße gehen oder vor allen Dingen ihren
Einfluss ihre Reichweiten nutzen
vielleicht auch ein bisschen Geld
generieren für diese Menschen das tun
sie nämlich nicht wenn Haare abschneiden
super war und ich habe wieder ein paar
likes generiert ja aber das ist bei
allen Themen die Mainstream sind sie
benutzen Sie sie werden benutzt
eigentlich mehr für die eigene Wirkung
als für die Sache an sich und das ist
das Traurige daran ja mach mal Kniefall
jetzt dafür mach meine Armbänder und das
Warten dann lassen sie wieder